today's one minute monday is scare
yourself this morning I reached out to
an old buddy of mine named George who
used to help out a lot in the salsa
classes i had on and he hasn't helped
for three years because he hurt his
shoulder and I said George I'm putting
on the class I really want you to come
out and help out I think it'd be a lot
of fun i miss you be great to see you
again and he said thanks so much for
reaching out you know what I love to but
i'm really scared I haven't danced in
three years and so George you got to do
something to scare yourself each day
right and he said you know what thanks
to the kick in the pants I'll come out
so for today I want you to scare
yourself do do one thing just today that
you have this limiting self belief about
that you're holding yourself back on do
one thing today that scares you a little
bit maybe it's reaching out to somebody
who you never thought would return your
phone call maybe it's emailing some
everything yes to a meeting something
think of something that you really want
that in your ideal world exists but
you're too afraid to go out and ask for
and just for today step outside your
comfort zone and go for it it'll make
you a stronger and better person and you
never know what will have believed you
guys like this video thumbs up below
leave a comment let me know what you
think let me know what you're going to
do today that scares you and click on my
face subscribe to the channel thank you
guys let's see you soon